bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france la situation en guyane inquiète
depuis quelques temps déjà des mois de
mars les syndicats de soignants ont
réclamé des moyens supplémentaires alors
des renforts ont bien été annoncée hier
mais ce qu'il n'arrive pas un peu tard
écoutez les renforts quand ils arrivent
sont toujours j'ai envie de dire la
bienvenue puisque on est dans une
situation inédite et donc forcément
personne n'y était vraiment préparé et
donc quand on n'a plus de moyens en tout
cas en guyane je ne peux que dire que
c'est une bonne chose maintenant il
n'est pas je pense que l'heure n'est pas
à re trouver qui est responsable qui a
mal fait de se retrouver tous ensemble
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que la
circulation du virus ont diminué sur le
territoire parce que aujourd'hui compte
on nous ramène des moyens des masses que
ça des choses qu'ils ne montent plus et
des problèmes qu'on avait au départ je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
encourageant l'autre point essentiel
c'est que je me permet de profiter de
l'antenne pour demander à tous les
hôpitaux en tout cas là où il ya des
personnels soignants qui puisse venir en
aide avec berne puisque on a besoin il y
aller les réanimateurs mais parfois
c'est le personnel qui monte pour
pouvoir armer j'ai envie de dire c'est
réanimateur et c'est également un très
faible nombre de lits en réanimation
c'est ce qu'a révélé aussi cette
épidémie ils sont deux fois moins
nombreux qu'en métropole pourquoi est ce
que les hôpitaux anglais sont-ils ces
sinistrés écoutez je n'ai pas la réponse
à ça puisque en tant que politique nous
ne faisons que tenté la voie du
personnel soignant que je tiens à saluer
pour leurs efforts leur courage leur
sacrifice et bien sûr l'hôpital en
guyane la santé notamment dans
l'intérieur parce qu'on parle souvent de
cayenne de saint laurent du maroni
mais allez voir sur les fleuves oyapock
et maroni la situation est d'autant plus
catastrophique
et donc il faut clairement réfléchir à
ça puisque lorsqu'on tombe malade à
maripasoula à camopi c'est bien pire que
ce qu'on vit à calais nous à saint
laurent du maroni ou encore à coup et
donc il faut clairement profité de cette
situation pour faire un travail un état
des lieux et demandé plus de moyens pour
les hôpitaux en viennent et on le voit
que clairement
on n'est pas à la hauteur avec la
gestion de cette crise maintenant j'ai
envie de dire quand le gouvernement
entend et commence à donner des moyens
on ne peut que saluer cet effort même si
il manque encore un certain nombre de
moyens mais l'effort et la volonté du
gouvernement moi je l' ai vécu je viens
d'arriver à paris avec la ministre on a
fait quand même deux jours en guyane et
donc je crois que c'est en commence à
aller dans le bon sens et comme je le
dis il ya des réanimateurs mais
malheureusement l'équipe de soignants
pour armer crs et réanimateurs il ya
rien véritablement donc je passe un
appel solennel
s'il vous plaît au sud ce cluster de
saint georges de l'oyapock puisque vous
l'avez évoqué ça se trouve dans le sud
de la région c'est une ville de passage
vers le brésil et inversement
quelques opérations à ce qu'il existe
aujourd'hui avec les autorités
brésiliennes pour contrôler au mieux
cette zone alors qu on le rappelle en le
brésil est extrêmement touché par corps
d'agnès et écoutez moi je l' ai signalé
dès le départ au préfet de région et
puis par la suite par question écrite à
la ministre c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
elle est venue en duel elle m'a certifié
que la meinau nous allons fermer
totalement la frontière o'neill entre le
brésil et la guyane c'est ce que je
demandais dans le sens où j'ai même
parlé avec des franco brésilien qui
disent qu'une personne ne doit rentrer
personne ne doit sortir en tout cas
pendant un moment dans l'ouest guyanais
navan le surinam qui a un peu plus de
300 cas aujourd'hui actif et il la
frontière est totalement fermé je ne
vois pas pourquoi dans l'est où il ya
plus de 18000 cas voire 25 mille cas
dans l'état de la mapa en ne ferme pas
la frontière donc ça serait un bon début
parce que quand le veuille ou non n'ont
pas l'idée de stigmatiser qui que ce
soit mais ça a été une ouverture passage
parce que les les garimpeiros où les
brésiliens ne rentre pas que par les
criques mais parfois entrent légalement
et donc c'est là le problème qui se pose
est est donc aujourd'hui la ministre a
dit que la frontière est totalement
fermé je ne peux que saluer cette
décision que je vous demandais que
d'autres collègues demandé depuis
toujours un mot de l'impact économique
de cette crise sanitaire qui enquêtent
également beaucoup en guyane quelques
pourtant la population est au chômage
c'est l'une des régions de france les
plus précarisés quelles solutions sont
mises en place par le gouvernement
écouter aujourd'hui les collectivités
locales en lance un certain nombre de
plans notamment les opci la collectivité
territoriale de duel il ya des aides
aussi au niveau de la bpi qui sans qui
pour encourager les entreprises
il ya un travail qui doit être fait avec
les collectivités pour les accompagner
puisque le sens des choses à acheter des
masses à chier des denrées alimentaires
pour alimenter l'intérieur et les
périphéries au niveau des différentes
communes puisque ce sont des territoires
à ces enclaves et tout ça c'est de
l'argent qui est qui sort mais qu'il
n'était pas prêt lui donc ces questions
là ils ont été posées dans quelques
minutes je vais me rendre au ministère
de la cohésion et des collectivités
territoriales pour voir sébastien
lecornu pourvoir et traiter ces sujets
là comment clairement on s'organise
puisque les collectivités sont bien sûr
en souffrance au niveau de leurs leurs
finances les entreprises aussi sont dans
une situation très difficile hier nous
avons reçu avec la ministre les
socioprofessionnels nous avons entendu
il en parler de délais de paiement mais
un certain nombre de choses pour
encourager notamment le nombre de vols
et toutes ces choses là et donc je crois
que on va dans le bon sens puisque il
faut de la concertation pour pouvoir
avancer vachement faux pas il faut
dénoncer certaines choses qui ne vont
pas il faut se retrouver autour de la
table pour pouvoir trouver des solutions
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions mais annie que
adam je rappelle que vous êtes député la
république en marche de billets